- Governors have mandated
generally, not all of them,
but most of them have said
there will be no elective surgeries.
Because we need to clear the hospitals
so that we can have beds
and equipment for people
with respiratory failure because of COVID.
Well, the unintended consequence of that
is that cancer patients
are forgoing treatment.
And a lot of hospitals are
on the verge of bankruptcy
because elective surgery
was a key part of their economic model.
So they've made things worse
by trying to make things better.
(upbeat music)
- Hey, I'm Dave Rubin and
according to the paperwork,
this is still the Rubin Report.
Friendly reminder, everybody to subscribe
to our YouTube channel
and click that pesky notification bell.
Joining me today is an author, a speaker,
and the host of Kibbe on Liberty
on the Blaze, Matt Kibbe.
Finally, welcome to the Rubin Report.
- Finally, hey Dave.
How's it going?
- It's going all right.
I have been on your show several times
and we were overdue to do it this way.
Flip the interviewer,
interviewee situation.
Every time I go on your show,
we spend about 80% of it talking
about Star Wars and Liberty.
So I feel like that's sort of
where we have to start here.
I'll just tell my audience right up front,
you're a big Liberty guy.
For those that don't know
you, you're a libertarian.
You've worked for Rand Paul,
you run a nonprofit, Free The People,
that spreads the ideas
of liberty and freedom.
We're gonna get far more into all of that
obviously related to
Coronavirus and everything else.
But I feel that I have to at
least allow you to pontificate
on Star Wars and explain a
little bit of how Star Wars,
at least the prequels, and the originals
do have a Liberty flair
that a lot of people don't know about.
- You know, per your recommendation
I actually went back
after the last show we did
and I rewatched the prequels
and I'll probably get
slaughtered for this,
but I think you're right.
I think the prequels may in
fact be the most relevant
and they may stand up to the test of time.
I can count at least 25, 30 governors
that want to be Palpatine right now.
(Dave laughs loudly)
So, which we should probably all go back
and watch this and see exactly
how freedom dies to thunderous applause.
Because I think we're
living this in real-time,
and all of these things
that governors are doing
seemed like fundamentally anti-democratic,
and it was all predicted in the prequels.
- It was all, and Jar Jar Binks,
who does that make Jar Jar
Binks in a modern sense.
- I don't know, I even
disliked him, less dislike him,
(Dave laughs softly)
dislike him less than I did before.
Which is shocking to me because
I just, I couldn't early on,
but I'm even pro Jar Jar at this point.
- Yeah, and probably dislike him less than
the way you dislike some
of the current governors,
also, I would imagine.
- Yeah, I mean, but that's a low bar.
So I'm giving Jar Jar more than that.
- Okay, so putting aside Star Wars,
although maybe we can
sort of weave it back
into this whole thing.
For those that don't know
you give me a little bit
of Matt Kibbe 101 background.
What got you into the Liberty
scene in the first place?
- So I was, my gateway drug to Liberty
was actually an album
by a band called Rush,
it's called 2112.
And you'll talk to a
number of libertarians,
particularly libertarians my
age, will tell you this story.
It was dedicated to
the genius of Ayn Rand.
I was 13 years old.
I had no idea who that dude Ayn Rand was,
but she had such an interesting name.
I went out and stumbled across an old copy
of her novella Anthem and I devoured it.
And I followed the breadcrumbs.
And eventually, Ayn Rand, if
you read her nonfiction stuff,
she says to read the Austrian economists
and specifically, Ludwig von Mises.
So I started reading all
that stuff when I was a kid.
And if nothing else,
it was the perfect way
to never get a date because
I couldn't get girls
that wanted to talk
about Austrian economics.
It's kind of strange.
- That's very bizarre.
Maybe you were doing it wrong somehow.
- Yeah, maybe, but I ended
up coming to the Death Star,
the belly of the beast, Washington, DC.
You go to graduate school
at George Mason University
to study economics and
eventually as it always does,
politics sort of sucks you in.
And I have all sorts of
horrible things in my past.
I was the Chief Economist for Lee Atwater
at the Republican National Committee.
I was budget director at
the US Chamber of Commerce
and eventually, I went on to found
a tea party organization
called FreedomWorks.
And that was ancient history now.
But I went from economist
to political hack
to grassroots organizer and
now hopefully communicator.
- Yeah, what actually interests you more?
I guess economics
fundamentally interests you
more than politics per se
because now we're very much
in the same space where we're sharing
the ideas of Liberty obviously.
But you have more of sort of
a schooling background in economics.
- Yeah, I mean, the
thing that I wanted to do
when I was a kid was write.
And I spent a lot of time writing.
I was one of those
awkward libertarian kids.
So you can imagine that
anything that doesn't involve
social interaction was
pretty attractive to me.
And I wanted to be a writer.
And I started off writing very
academic stuff and you know,
if you were lucky you could get 10 people
to read your peer-reviewed
article with all the footnotes,
and all the fancy words that
we academics like to use
to pretend that we know more than we do.
But I wrote my first
Wall Street Journal piece
and I just did the math and
I realized, you know what,
if I could learn how to
communicate in plain English,
I could probably reach
a much broader audience.
And that's definitely
what we tried to do today.
We don't do a lot of
writing and free the people,
but we use video storytelling
to try to sort of
bridge the language divide between people
that would identify with
different political tribes.
Because I do believe that
Liberty is a human value.
It's built into our systems
and if we could figure out
a way to listen to people
that are sort of Liberty curious,
and try to connect with them,
I think that would grow
our community in a way
that just speaking
economics will never do.
- Yeah, I should mention, by the way,
we've already been
talking for a few minutes
and I did not point out
that for a libertarian
you're dressed fairly well.
You know you go to a
libertarian conference,
you got naked people, you
got people with crazy shirts.
Look at you, I mean you have a tie on,
your jacket and shirt
seemed to fit appropriately.
Are you sure you're hanging
with the right crew?
What's going on over there?
- This is kind of a forest
quarantine counter-revolution.
Because I've worn all
of my concert t-shirts,
and I haven't showered for days,
but I decided that if I'm gonna
start breaking quarantine,
which is where I'm at
now, I need to look good.
The problem is I still
don't have pants on.
So it's gonna somehow, it's
probably going to be awkward
if I go outside.
- You and me both
brother, you and me both.
But let's not this is a family show,
so we'll leave it at that.
Okay, so I think having you on now
was sort of the perfect time because
if Liberty ever needed a
jolt or if it ever was about
to have a resurgence, I
think both of those things
are sort of possible right now.
I sense that we need it more than ever,
at least in modern times right now.
And that it could be on the cusp
of really gaining momentum right now.
So give me your basic breakdown
of sort of where we're at
with Corona, sort of what you
thought we should have done.
What was the appropriate
Liberty-minded response,
say two months ago in this first thing
was rolling out to kind
of where we are right now.
- So my initial reaction
and I went back and checked,
the first piece I wrote about the pandemic
was I think March 16th.
So pretty early on I actually wrote it
on a beach in Jost Van
Dyke, I was on vacation
and we had to cancel it.
To get back to the United States
before I was afraid they were
gonna close the airports.
And me being a geek, I wrote this piece.
But I was worried that
centralized top-down
one size fits all solutions,
the very complex problems
was inevitably going to
create a lot of unintended
and destructive consequences.
And I was thinking about
one of my economist heroes
Frederic Bastiat, and he talks about
the seen and the unseen.
And the inability of people to conceive of
the incredibly complex division of labor
that brings food to your table every day.
You don't know how it happened
and you can see that playing out now.
People just assumed
that food would show up.
And so when grocery
store shelves are empty,
they start panicking
and frankly, they start blaming markets
when in fact it was meddling
into the market process
that created that.
And so not even conceiving
that we would do
these massive never-ending lockdowns
the way the governors did.
I was worried that the
government was going to do
all sorts of things that
would make it more difficult
to deal with not just the
disease and the virus.
But all the other things we need to do
to keep our families safe.
And one of those things is earning income.
Another is put food on the table.
A third is actually being
able to take care of yourself
and go outside maybe get cancer treatments
and all these things that are
now proving impossible to do.
So knowing the government fails,
I was afraid that they were
gonna fail philosophy bad.
And that's kind of where we're at.
- Okay, so I think most of
my audience will be with you
on the, "Okay, we don't like
the top-down version of this.
"We want to figure out sort of local-level
"individual stuff first."
What I see a lot of people
on the Twitter saying is,
"Oh, this shows the
flaw of libertarianism.
"This shows the flaw of small government
"because, in a time like this,
a pandemic knows no borders.
"We need strong national decisions
that are across the board
"and the rest of it."
How do you combat that concept?
- Well, I think the entire
purpose of the market process,
and I call it a mutual support system.
The entire purpose of
people getting together
and cooperating and trading
and engaging in ideas
is because we live in a
radically uncertain world.
What happened yesterday
is in no way tells us
what's gonna happen tomorrow.
And the whole point for that process
is for people to figure
out really complex things
that are going to happen to us.
And it feels like this exogenous shock,
this natural disaster of a global pandemic
is exactly what you want to
decentralize system to solve.
And on top on that,
how much government officials don't know.
We always talk about market failure,
but we never talk about
government failure.
And you can check some of these boxes,
some of the horrific things that federal
and state governments have
done since the beginning
of this pandemic to
screw up the food supply.
To, you remember this
supposedly cache of N95 masks.
- Oh yeah, oh yeah.
- How many administration you gonna have?
Well, guess what, government
fails, it always fails,
because politics is a horrible way
to solve complex problems.
So when you combine those two things,
if you're gonna shut off
the ingenuity of free people
to solve problems.
And replace it with the central plan,
that is by definition going
to be dysfunctional and wrong.
That's where you get
really, really bad things
in our society.
- Do you sense that a lot
of the divide on the people
that view the world
top-down versus the people
that view the world bottom up.
That it's just a fundamental
psychological conditioning
that they have.
That it's not just, "Oh, we learned,
"we have different economic
policies let's say."
But that their fear centers
are different or you know,
I find when I hear all
the big government people.
They seem to have this trust in a thing
just because the thing exists.
So it's sort of inherently must be good
because it existed or maybe
50 years ago it was better
or something like that.
Versus I think people more
in line with our thinking,
where it's like, "Well,
just because it exists,
"it doesn't mean it's inherently good.
"So I want to just scale the power back."
Do you think that how much
a certain amount of this
is just your psychological makeup?
- You know, it may be that
and not to sort of castigate
my progressive friends.
But I think people don't appreciate
just how much we don't
know as individuals.
And how much our leaders don't know,
even though they went to
all the right colleges
and have all of these credentials.
And so maybe there's a line
in the sand about humility
and being willing to say in
public what is this new pandemic
and how does it compare to past pandemics
and what don't we know?
If some of these modelers would have said,
you know what, there's no
way that I could model this
in an honest way.
So let me tell you the
things that we do know.
But let me also tell you
that if I project numbers,
there's no way it's going to be right.
It's always going to be wrong.
And that sort of goes
back to the old dream
of a progressivism.
That you could take science
and science was settled
and really smart people that
went to the right colleges
could take that science and
impose it on the rest of us.
And we would have this
sort of rationally planned
top-down society.
But that lacks humility.
It lacks any sense that you
couldn't possibly know enough
to plan a complex economy.
And this was Rhetoric
Hayek's, entire critique
of socialist planning.
And I think it applies
to any would-be planner,
even some of the governors
and how they're telling us
all in a very microcosmic way
like you should do this
and you shouldn't do that.
- Yeah, we talked about this a little bit
when I was on your show
a couple of weeks ago,
but do you think some of
this sort of also is just
the end of secularism?
In a weird way, it's the end of just,
Oh, people, just creating
systems in the moment
that aren't necessarily experts
and that the experts get everything wrong.
And that we just keep sort of outsourcing
all of our decision making.
And every day we wake
up and as you're saying
yesterday doesn't really
form what tomorrow will be.
And that we've just sort of hit the end
of what we can build in a weird way.
Something like that.
- Yeah, like there's definitely
been this democratization
and decentralization, disintermediation.
My wife hates it when I use that word.
Because it doesn't mean
anything to anybody,
but technology has democratized
knowledge and information.
And I happen to be one of those
guys that was super romantic
about the potential to
decentralize everything
based on that.
But it seems like there's a backlash now.
And you have clickbait
and you have censorship
and you have all of these things
where sort of the empire striking back
to get back to that phase.
- I knew you'd get there.
I knew you'd get there.
- The experts do not like the fact
that we probably don't
need to go to school
to figure out electrical engineering.
We probably don't need to
defer to epidemiologists
because we could actually do some
of that research for ourselves.
And discover that there is
patterns and there is history
and all that stuff is available to us.
I think in a lot of ways
the backlash by the planners
is because we were
actually needing them less.
And they see an opportunity right now
to reconsolidate power and take it back.
- So I'm very much along that,
that's what this feels to me.
That they had almost
completely been decimated.
We've all sort of woken
up to the idea that,
you know, a four-year college
that you're gonna spend 120
grand on isn't necessary.
And you know, that all of these
giant institutions are failing.
And we'll talk a little
bit more about journalism
in just a sec.
So you really think, do you
think though that this is
some sort of coordinated move then
by that establishment or
those institutions to do this?
I mean, this is where we get into
like some strange conspiracy stuff.
But these days, anyone who's
not a conspiracy theorist
isn't really thinking, you know,
when you're trapped in your house all day.
- Well, I don't believe
in grand conspiracies
because of the natural
failures of governments
and everything else.
But you know, you go back to Adam Smith
and I won't quote the quote
because I'll butcher it,
but the natural tendency
of business people
and others to conspire to hold up prices.
This is part of human nature.
And you don't have to
be a conspiracy theorist
to understand that the incentives align
with all of the people
that are using this crisis
to radically expand
the power of the state.
You know, the collusion, and
we've talked about this before.
The collusion between government experts
and social media czars
who are now deciding
which scientists we get to hear from,
which economists, which opinions,
and it's gotten really absurd.
I don't think that's a grand conspiracy.
I just think their incentives
align and they want control
and they want control of the narrative.
They want control of the market,
they want control of government power,
whatever it is they're trying to control.
This works perfectly
because people are nervous,
people are anxious.
There's radical uncertainty right now
and people are exploiting it.
- Okay, so let's back up a little bit.
So with all this in mind, let's
pretend Kibbe's President,
it's 2020 America has some
sort of, you know, libertarian.
I don't like to say libertarian utopia
because I don't think libertarians
really believe in utopia
in the way that progressives
tend to believe in it.
But we have, you know, some sort of
more liberty-minded state,
may be that the founders had planned.
And you're president and
you start getting all
these communiques and
messages about Coronavirus.
Is the first thing that
you do as a president
to tell all of the governors,
"You guys just handle this
"and when you need help you call us.
"But I'm not gonna do anything with that."
Would that be the sort of liberty take
on what the president
should be doing right now?
- It would definitely be federalism
but to take it even a
step further localism
and even individualism.
Ayn Ryan famously said that
the discriminated minority
is the individual.
And I think that even at the local level,
there can be tyranny if governments
get too full of themselves.
And the key to really complex problems,
things you don't know anything about
is tapping into local
knowledge and problem-solving.
And this is what governors
are getting wrong.
So I don't think federalism
is going to solve our problem.
You know that the libertarian joke
is that we're conspiring
to take over the government
so they'll leave you alone.
And I guess that would be my
mandate if I was president,
God helped me.
But it gets back to the humility thing.
And you see this playing
out in very practical ways.
Governors have mandated,
generally, not all of them.
But most of them has said there will be
no elective surgeries because
we need to clear the hospitals
so that we can have beds and equipment
for people with respiratory
failure because of COVID.
Well, the unintended consequence of that
is that cancer patients
are forgoing treatment
and a lot of hospitals are
on the verge of bankruptcy
because elective surgery
was a key part of the economic model.
So they've made things worse
by trying to make things better.
The only people that would know for sure
what the right policy would be
to make sure that a hospital
was safe and well run
and had capacity.
Would be to let doctors and patients
and hospital administrators
in that community
figure that stuff out for themselves.
That's gotta be the way
that we get out of this mess
now that we've created it.
But that would be my take.
- What is the inherent problem with that,
that the blue state governors
and the lefties more generally?
They don't view paying for these things
or hospitals having to,
you know, pay people
or any of these things as necessary.
It's sort of, "Oh well do
whatever you're supposed to do,"
as they define it and
then we'll pay for it.
Meaning we'll just
magically make up numbers.
So logic is just sort
of coming against like
a black hole in a certain regard.
- I think a lot of governors
have suddenly discovering that
if they close down all the businesses,
there won't be any revenue
to pay for all of the--
- Incredible.
- And now they're of course
going to the Federal Government
begging for bailout there.
And I hope we don't give it to them
because that'll just
reward really bad behavior.
But there is like a
shocking naivete about,
and I said this earlier, how
does food get on the table?
But where does all that revenue come from
that funds all of these programs?
How do hospitals stay in business?
It's very much a market
that allows for that
where you have customers
and you have people selling services.
And you know, for some
reason we don't think that
that's appropriate in healthcare.
But it's essential if you
actually want access to a doctor
when you're diagnosed with cancer.
And no amount of empty government promises
are a substitute for that.
And we're gonna learn this right now.
All of these generous
unemployment benefits,
all of people that are
on Medicaid and Medicare.
These programs are gonna get
squeezed like never before
because there's just
gonna be a total collapse
in government revenue.
And they're hoping that
the feds bill them out.
But the feds don't have any money either.
So we're gonna print it.
And there's all sorts of like,
this would be a different
program about what's gonna happen
when all that stuff happens.
But everyone thinks that their resources
are just like this
exogenous thing out there.
That magic is there and all
we gotta do is redivide it.
It now it's gonna disappear
and then we're gonna discover
what that sort of social
justice model is gonna lead to.
And it's gonna make everybody less safe.
Everybody less healthy,
everybody more hungry.
And I hope there's some
ownership of that, but we'll see.
- So going on the assumption
there is an ownership of that
because that doesn't seem
to be how inertia works.
Or there might at least be states that
sort of own it themselves.
So you know, Florida and Texas for example
with zero state income
tax are doing nice jobs,
balancing their budgets.
And I do sense there's sort
of idea floating around
the internet right now.
That in effect what
New York and California
particularly are doing,
is they're trying to absolutely
tank their own economies
because they're so screwed.
And I say this as someone
that grew up in New York
and now lives in California.
That they have so screwed themselves
despite 13% income tax that
I pay here in California
on top of LA you know, city tax.
That they have no way of getting out.
So it's like destroy, let's
blow up the whole thing
knowing the feds will have to
come in and clean up the mess.
I know you're not for that,
but do you think that
that's actually possible?
That's really what like
Newsome's really sitting around
going, we're looking at the numbers,
there's no way out of this
and let's just blow up the
whole damn thing and force...
We'll stick it to Trump.
Something like that.
- Yeah, I think it's clearly
part of their strategy.
They don't have any, they
don't seem to have any concern
about actually cleaning
up their own house.
So they're gonna look for that bailout.
But let me, we talked
about conspiracy theories.
Let me take it a step further.
James Cliburn, who is
Nancy Pelosi's number three
in the house.
In early March when they were debating
that first trillion-dollar bill,
which turned into a $2.2 trillion bill.
He said to his colleagues,
"This is an opportunity to remake America
"the way that we want to see it happen."
And I think there's a
method to this madness.
When you give people such
extravagant unemployment benefits
that employers can't hire them back
because they're making a ton
more money being unemployed.
That sounds like something
that AOC would love to see
because she told us all
not to go back to our jobs.
- Yeah, she doesn't find
that there's no value
in work basically.
- Yeah, and we all know that
that's economically ignorance.
But what if this is a
process to radically expand
the welfare of state?
Like if you're putting a
third of Americans out of work
and you're giving them
these generous benefits,
at what point is any
Republican or Democrat
kind of roll that back?
They never get rolled back.
Temporary programs become permanent.
But you know, the other piece of this,
which I think is even more ominous,
is this tracking system
that they're developing.
Where if you do decide
to go to our restaurant,
there's gonna be some
government bureaucrat.
They're wanting your
information so that they can get
in contact with you later.
That sounds like something the
communist Chinese would do.
And yet all this--
- If we want to do the conspiracy thing,
then it's like, wow, maybe
China unleash this knowing all
these stupid things that we
would then do to ourselves.
- Well, it is sort of, I don't know if
they did it on purpose, but if
we do adopt the Chinese model
based on, by the way,
huge government failures
that originated in China.
One government failure after another,
and all of a sudden we're
like, let's be like China
then America's done.
Like we're just done if
we're not gonna push back.
But to your point, like the only way
that the governor of California
and the governor of New York
are held accountable
is if the people do it.
And it's gotta be bottom-up.
The same logic that applies to markets,
applies to political pressure.
And I'm not talking about voting,
I'm talking about the people
that drive public opinion
that actually shape what
politicians will do tomorrow.
That's where this revolution has to start.
It's gotta be peaceful it's
gotta be civilly disobedient.
And you're seeing it in the streets
and on the beaches today.
People are like, "We're done.
"You guys lied to us.
"You told us that we're
flattening the curve
"and now you won't let
us out of our houses.
We're just done."
- All right Kibbe, so
then I want some advice
as a guy that lives in California.
I mean, I've been tweeting about this
and Fox News ran a Chiron I didn't realize
they were going to when I
was on Dana Perino that said,
"Dave Rubin, is considering
leaving California
because of a tweet."
But I do sense that the
rubbers meeting the road
with my ideas.
I believe in federalism.
I believe in all the
things you're talking about
and state's rights and the foot vote
and all of those things.
Do you think it's worth it
in a place like California
for liberty-minded people and let's say,
right-leaning people, whatever that is,
they stay in fight or is
this thing too far gone?
What do you actually think?
- I think there's a very strong argument
for fleeing these States
that are so authoritarian.
And by the way, I should own up the fact
I live in the district of Columbia,
and my mayor is every bit as
authoritarian as your governor.
We're locked down until June as well.
Here and she's not releasing
the data, the modeling--
- No data no nothing.
- And she thinks she is good.
She says she has it but she
won't tell us what it is.
So I'm in the same boat as you.
I'm living literally in
the belly of the beast.
I'm two blocks from the Capitol right now
and I've been trying to convince my wife
to let me flee to a red state.
I actually think there's going
to be a political realignment
that's not so much red versus blue.
It's gonna be governors
that had the humility
to let free people rebuild the mess
that our governments have made.
And people are gonna
vote with their feets.
This is why we like federalism
because there is
competition between states.
I think Texans are a little worried
that too many of you
Californians are gonna move there
and break everything that they've done.
- Well, that's where everybody, you know,
people in Colorado are worried about that.
People in Arizona are worried about that.
That seems to happen.
California's raised taxes
on themselves, the state crumbles,
and then they export these idiotic ideas.
I'd almost be for Texas having
some sort of test to get in.
I know they can't really do that,
like some sort of like,
you can't come here
to suddenly institute a state income tax
or something like that.
But all right, so with
that in mind though,
for people that believe in federalism
that believe that the way we
set this thing up was right.
If what you're saying is right,
and I've been thinking about this a lot,
it's almost like, not to
say we're gonna end up
in a civil war.
But we are gonna then have to
actually watch states fail.
That's an almost unimaginable
idea for a lot of people,
don't you think?
- Yeah, I mean, it's
gonna be very difficult.
I could count on one and maybe two hands
the number of Republicans
that I think have sort of
the testicular fortitude to say no
to bailing out California.
And you know who those guys are.
And there aren't very many others
that are willing to do that.
And so much about politics
is driven by their fear
of not getting reelected,
their fear that someone's
gonna call them a bad person
because they didn't do that.
But if you actually
want federalism to work,
you can't bail out states
that have behaved so badly.
You know, California was broke
long before this pandemic
and everything they've done since then
has only exacerbated their
ability to grow their way
out of it once we get past the pandemic.
It's gotta be held accountable.
And this gets back to
this political realignment
that I'm thinking about.
I was, you know this, I
was a tea party organizer
in 2008 when Nancy Pelosi and John Boehner
walked down the aisle of
the house floor and said,
"We must bail out Wall Street together."
And the American people rose up
because they had access
to information online.
That to me was the day that I
think the tea party was born
in opposition for the
Wall Street bailouts.
And by the way, in the beginning,
it wasn't a partisan thing at all.
Occupy wall street had some
of the same predilections
and some of the revolts
against the injustices of that.
I think the lockdowns are
that same seismic shock
on our political alignment
and we'll see where the chips fall.
But I think there's an
opportunity out of this disaster
to get people to pay a
little more attention
to what the government's doing to them.
- It's interesting
because as you're saying
that you'd love to convince
your wife to get moving
and you know, we're having
those same discussions here.
I'm kind of with you on
what you just said there,
which is maybe this is the shock.
Maybe the average Californian is gonna go,
"Whoa, this just does not make sense.
"What have we done,"
now that's putting maybe
a little too much faith
in people waking up?
But that's the part of me
that wants to stay in fight
because I do love it here.
That's the part that's like,
"All right, dig in for,"
you know, we try it for
like two, three more years
to see if in the aftermath this
thing can rebuild properly.
I don't know that it's possible, you know,
maybe that's a little to
rose-colored glasses or something.
- Well, I'm a libertarian.
That has been most of my
career in Washington DC.
So I'm perfectly building
chase impossible rainbows.
- Yeah, if the states actually
do go these separate ways,
do you think we have enough
of a national ethos anymore
to keep us together as a nation?
'Cause that seems like the
next step down the road
with this, right?
- Yeah, it's become increasingly worrisome
the way with this tribal divide
and how everything is political now.
And it's always red versus blue
even for most of us who
don't even identify with
either one of those tribes.
And that the authoritarian
left us so western libertarian
like me away from it.
We're all looking for a home
and I still think that
classical liberalism
or libertarianism or humility.
Just call it the kind of humility
that your mom tried to teach you.
That to me is the only thing
that holds us together.
Because if we're going
to use the reins of power
at the state level, at the federal level
to force everybody to
live just the way that
we believe they should live.
I don't see how that doesn't
get violent at some point
because the alternative has to
be peaceful cooperation, tolerance.
You live your life exactly how you want,
as long as you don't
hurt me or take my stuff.
There is a solution here and
that solution, by the way,
was very much built into
the American blueprint
with the declaration of
independence and the bill of rights
in the constitution.
So we're gonna have to revisit that.
And yeah, getting back
to this counterrevolution
that we hope will happen.
It's gotta start there because that is the
only solution that keeps us together.
- Yeah, because I could
also see a situation
where the red state people,
so now you're in Texas,
you know you have your
no state income tax,
you still have federal income tax.
But you're going, wait a minute,
"Why am I paying all this money to the fed
"to bail out the guys that who
screwed up the whole thing?"
So I could see an average Texan
who's living their life,
doing everything properly,
following the law, voting
in the right type of people.
Becoming seriously resentful
of people in another state,
and that that's deeply dangerous.
You mentioned classical
liberalism of course.
So I have to ask you the question
that every single
interviewer I think asked me
on my book tour.
Which is do you see any
meaningful distinction
between classical liberalism
and libertarianism?
Does it even matter or is
this just for the wonky guys
to sit around after
libertarian conferences,
have a drink, and whittle it away?
- Well, of course, there's
only one perfect libertarian
and that's me and everybody else.
That's a libertarian joke, but right.
Because we spend so much time
arguing about the minutia.
So I actually don't think
there's a difference.
And I could, depending on
who I'm trying to speak to,
and I don't think there's
any contradiction in this.
I either use the word libertarian,
which Hayek says is a made-up word.
He likes the word liberal.
But now we have to qualify it
by saying classical liberal
so that people appreciate
that it's different
than how it might be used today.
But I think constitutional conservative
is kinda the same thing
because we all may have
personal preferences
and lifestyle choices that
we make that are different.
But in terms of governance
and how we cooperate
with each other, it's the same philosophy.
It's all about that
localism that bottom-up.
There's a couple rules, don't hurt people,
don't take their stuff.
Other than that, we all get along.
And if you want to go
to church, go to church.
If you don't want to go to
church, don't go to church.
I don't really care because I'm minding
enough of my own business
the way my mom taught me to.
- Yeah, no, I'm with you on that.
So I'm gonna ask you one or two sorts of
the core libertarian things.
Where are you at with open borders?
This is one of the ones where
when I talk to the more
libertarian minded people
like I am completely
not an open borders guy.
I get some of the arguments.
I'd be happy for you to lay
out some of the arguments
if you are.
But this is one of the ones
where I think especially now
I think the more nationalists,
and I don't mean nationalists
in a scary word, nationalists.
I believe we're nations and
we can set our own borders
and things like that.
I think Trump has some wins on that
coming in the election
because of Coronavirus,
our ability to control our own borders.
But I know a lot of
libertarians don't like that.
They want free trade,
free complete ability
to bounce across everywhere all the time.
Where are you at on that?
- So I used to be for open borders,
but now I've sort of changed my position
because I do think we need to build a wall
between California and America.
(laughs loudly)
Because it's very dangerous.
- Can I just get a date
on that 'cause gonna get myself--
- Yeah, but you know, I used to,
I have a more libertarian
view on you than this.
I used to give speeches,
to tea party audiences,
I talked to progressive audiences
and my view is the same.
If you want to come to
this country and work,
and follow the rules we want you.
And I don't think you need to build a wall
to enforce a rule like that.
What you need to do is get
politics out of the process
of getting the people here that wanna work
and wanna follow the rules.
Because right now the system,
these games there are some Republicans
that don't want any immigration.
There are some Democrats that
don't want any immigration
because it undermines union power.
And there are other Democrats that
once people get here illegally,
they want to sort of own
and control them.
So the whole thing is super political.
And I think the answer's
got to be a simplification
of the process so that if
guest workers want to come
and they wanna follow the rules,
and they want to and or if
they wanna become a citizen
and be an American.
I think those processes should
be predictable and unpolitical.
And I think if you did those things,
you could focus border
security on violent gangs
that are running drugs
across the Mexican border.
You could repeal a drug war,
which would also get rid of the two gangs.
There's all sorts of
free-market things you could do
that I think would solve
some of the concerns
that conservatives have
about border security
without building a wall.
So I am more libertarian on that,
but I don't think it's unreasonable
because of so many of the things
that do make America great
come from immigrants
that came to this country
and added value and built
this beautiful quilt
that is America.
So I don't wanna shut that down.
- Yeah, and actually it doesn't sound
like we're very far off on that.
I always say I'm not sort of
for a wall or against a wall.
If you told me there were
certain parts of the border
that we could prove a wall
would be particularly effective.
And there have been some places like that,
then I'm okay with that.
But I don't like the idea of,
you know, the 3000-mile wall,
just so that we have
this idea of protection
when in many ways we're
not gonna be doing that.
And then, you know, I'm sorta, well,
where are you at on like
pathway to citizenship
for the 12 million or
so people that are here.
What do you, do you put them
back at the back of the line
or how do we even get these
guys to come out of the shadows
and the rest of it?
- Yeah, I mean, I think
that I would be for
a pathway of citizenship
and it's easy to say that
and I think politics would screw it up.
But I think a better way
to solve that problem
is that a lot of people
that came here illegally,
probably would prefer a
reliable guest-worker program
so they could go back home
and be with their families.
I have lots of friends in
the free market community
in Latin America, in
Honduras for instance.
And I hear the story
again and again and again,
that the reason that people are
illegal in the United States
is that they don't have the confidence
that they could come
and go with the seasons,
say they're picking crops
or whatever they're doing,
they can't do that.
So I feel like the path
to citizenship thing
is almost a changing of the conversation
because we're primarily
talking about people.
They just wanna do work that's
actually available to them
and they're doing it
because their economies
are so screwed up in Honduras.
But the American drug war
has given all the power
to the drug gang.
So families are making that
march because they're desperate,
it's not a choice they would make.
So again, I think there's
probably a freedom-based solution
that doesn't reward illegal behavior,
but would get people
to voluntarily go back
if there was a predictable
process by which
they could come back and forth
based on employment opportunities.
- So where are you
generally at with Trump?
Who I think the name
Trump was only mentioned
once in this entire
interview, just a moment ago.
I sense with most libertarians,
they kinda like a lot of
the stuff Trump has done,
regulation cut taxes.
We don't seem to be going to extra wars.
If anything we're trying to
get out of Afghanistan now
and we're not gonna be nation-building.
That's all very libertarian stuff.
I think a lot of libertarians
and one night we were at,
I think it was a Yale conference
and we had a table of libertarians.
And it seemed very obvious
to me that everyone's sort of
like the things he was doing
but just had a personal
they just don't like him personally.
Like it was that idea.
And I sense that a lot of
people have that thing.
Is that kinda where you are?
What do you make of this
whole thing with Trump?
Trump and the Liberty-minded people
'cause obviously he's not his core is not
a Liberty-minded core, he
would love to take more power
if he could,
but yet it seems like he's
doing a pretty decent job.
- You know he has, he does have a sort of
an authoritarian mindset
and I'm not even convinced
he's ever read the bill of rights.
So I guess that's an
excuse, but full disclosure,
and you mentioned this.
I did work for Rand Paul super back
when he was running for president
and then I ran a Gary
Johnson Super Pac after that.
So as a candidate I was a never Trumper
because I had a candidate
and his name wasn't Trump.
As president, it's a
totally different thing.
And I'll go back to when
Barack Obama was president.
I spent a lot of my time
organizing the tea party
and opposing the stimulus and
the bailouts and Obamacare
and all that stuff.
But when he wanted to do
criminal justice reform,
I went to the justice department
and worked with Eric Holder
in hopes to get something done.
My attitude with Trump
is kind of the same way.
When he's good, I wanna work with him.
I've done lots of shows supporting him
on things like criminal justice reform,
staying out of so many permanent wars,
and stuff like that that he's done.
But on other things that
libertarians care a bunch about
you know, we just had a
vote on surveillance power
and whether or not the deep
state would get more power.
Trump's been horrible on that.
And I don't know if it's
bad advisors or what,
if you care about dept and spending
Trump's been horrible on that.
So it's a mixed bag, but our
job when we have a president
is to make them better.
And so I don't spend all my
time railing about Trump.
I'm hoping that he will
do some of the things
that would make more sense.
And I was hopeful, for instance,
that he would be a strong
voice on reopening the economy.
But he's been a little
hard to understand on this.
He spent a lot of time
picking on the Governor of Georgia, Kemp,
who was one of the first to
unlock down their economy.
So even on that, it's
a mixed bag with Trump.
But you know, I'm a libertarian.
I don't really get on board
with big government whether
Republican or Democrat.
- You mean you don't think Trump can solve
all of your personal problems?
Is that what you're telling me?
- I kind of want to live in a world where
I don't have to worry
who the president is.
That's how naive I am.
Like if you had a president.
- (laughs loudly) Yeah, I'm with you man.
- Yeah.
- All right, so let's move off Trump.
You mentioned Rand Paul and
since you did work with him
for a little bit.
I had him on last week, and
one of the things that I said
to him was sort of exactly
what you just laid out
there about Trump.
Which is that one of the
reasons I'm more okay
now with Trump is that
Rand Paul has become
one of his biggest allies.
And, it's interestingly, 'cause
Paul's explanation of why
he's okay with Trump is
sort of what you just said
that yeah, there's good, there's bad,
but I can try to push him the
best I can on the good stuff
and the rest of it.
So in a weird way, it
almost seems to be that
that's the best libertarians can do.
We're not particularly good at
getting candidates out there,
but you know, the party is
just an absolute disaster.
You want to explain a little
bit about why the party
seems to be such a disaster.
Even though so many of the
ideas if you could get people
to listen to them, they are right.
And again, maybe sort of getting
us back to the beginning.
Maybe they are about
to have a real moment.
- Yeah, so personally I just
wanna out that both Rand Paul
and Mike Lee are in a
highly leveraged position
in the Senate.
And they on any given vote,
they could be the difference
between passing and not passing.
And I think they both
done a very good job.
You know, neither one of
them obviously Rand Paul
ran against Trump and Mike
Lee supported Ted Cruz
in the primaries,
but they've sort of have
stepped up and said,
"Mr. President, I'm gonna work
with you on the things that
we share in common and I'm
gonna try to convince you
on some other things."
And I think that's a
really smart thing to do.
And libertarians that criticized that
I don't really understand
because the point is
to get the right policy.
The point's not to sort of virtue signal
that Trump's an awful guy.
And but for the libertarian party
and third parties, generally,
I think that there is
inevitably a moment where
the two-party duopoly does break up.
And the reason I think
that the libertarian party
has struggled so much is that
it is the two parties that set the rules
by which political parties operate.
And Gary Johnson was a
great example of that.
They kept changing the
rules of how you got
onto the presidential stage.
By any historical measure,
Gary Johnson would have been
on that stage.
But they keep changing the
rules and that makes it
very difficult for parties to compete.
Because if you're raising
money for politics,
the value pitch that you make to donors is
we can win this race.
For a third party and
not just libertarians
but greens or
constitutionalists or whatever.
The two parties that
control all the power,
make it virtually impossible
for them to compete.
And it's usually some accident
like say Abraham Lincoln,
that creates a new third party.
It's gonna happen but it's kind
of a chicken and egg thing.
The Libertarian Party
would have ballot access
in all 50 States.
Would have a better donor base,
would attract more talent if
they were allowed to compete
and I dunno how that breaks through.
They gotta breakthrough somehow.
- Yeah, so you're saying
it's not the naked guy
running on stage that's
gonna breakthrough,
is that what you're saying?
- (laughs loudly) So
when I was raising money
for Gary Johnson, I had brought on
some Republican donors major guys
that were finally paying attention
to The Libertarian Party.
And they tuned in to that
convention on C-SPAN.
And the first thing they saw,
was a fat hairy naked guy
and they were like, "Yeah, okay."
(laughs loudly)
Thanks.
- There's other places to spend my money.
- Yeah, that of course that
was before imposed lockdowns
where none of us are really
wearing pants anymore.
- Exactly, there you go, so, all right.
So to just sort of bring
this full circle then,
so with all of these
ideas and with us still
in these rolling lockouts,
you in DC me in California,
we're watching Texas and Florida.
Are you worried that the
biggest disaster looming
actually sort of directly
Coronavirus related,
is that if there's suddenly a bump,
let's say in two weeks
in Texas or Florida.
Which in a weird way, it
almost feels inevitably
will have to happen because
that's sort of the risk
that they're playing with.
That the media will use that
as such a freaking hammer
to prove that they should
have never opened up.
That it basically puts DC,
New York, and California
in perpetual lockdown, and
then it actually scares.
I'm doing the reverse at
the silver lining thing now.
It actually scares the
people who have been fighting
for their freedom enough to shut up.
And then next thing you
know, Texas and Florida
are back in lockdown.
- Yeah, I think it's a real risk.
You know, historically and
I'm not an epidemiologist,
but I've read so much.
We all have just trying to
figure out what the hell
is going on.
And in the during the Hong Kong flu,
there was very much a
peak in the winter of 68
and a second peak in the winter of 69.
In the summer, things
settled down a little bit.
In that particular one, the
peak wasn't in the same places.
So San Francisco was a
hotbed in the first peak
of the Hong Kong flu.
So how this plays out I don't know,
but I look at the same data
that people on the other side
are looking at.
I look at what's going on in Sweden.
I look at what's going on in
New York and other places,
and the way that people manipulate
data to tell their story
is deeply frustrating to me.
So yes, we might have
a beautiful revolution
that discovers humility and localism
and American freedom again.
Or this could be the cudgel
that big government types
use to permanently
implement social tracing
to permanently implement
the massive welfare state
where most Americans don't work anymore.
To permanently implement
government-run healthcare.
All of these things that
they've wanted to do,
they're trying to do it now.
And if they're gonna keep demonizing,
they're going to keep
demagoguing and the media
is gonna keep helping them.
So we're going to have to create
that alternative narrative,
and pretty much, no matter
what's happens with the virus.
- All right, so we started at Star Wars,
we're ending in dystopian future,
so let's add a little
more dystopia to it then.
We'll see if maybe we can
end this on a positive note.
Big tech, just talk to
me about your feelings.
We've talked about it a whole bunch.
I do not want government regulating this.
I think if you have one huge problem
and another huge problem,
then you combine them
into the Voltron of problems.
That is not good.
Do you think there is a way we can survive
this technological adolescence
where we've already all
conceded all of our information,
we have no idea how we're being
manipulated with algorithms
and shadow banning and the rest of it.
Has the ship just totally sailed?
Do you think that competition
can fix any of this?
Where we at?
- We talked about this last
time and the way that YouTube
is essentially doing the bidding
of international health organizations
when they decide what is true and false.
Is a new level of
dystopian 1984 spout creepy
and I think they're gonna
pay a price for that.
The alternative is
people seeing that happen
and seeing videos that are banned
or for nothing that is even
slightly controversial.
Just having a different
opinion about something.
I think there's gonna be
a lot of other platforms
and I'm seeing people are
now posting those same videos
on their websites.
I can tell you free the people's websites
and all of our videos.
It's gone up 82% in the last month or so.
And I think that's probably
natural because people are
getting off of those
dictated censored platforms
and moving to other things.
And you know, you're
gonna have to do that too
because ultimately they're
gonna kick us all off
and we're just gonna have
to prepare for that day.
- That felt good.
And then right at the
end then the prepare part
got depressing again.
Give me some libertarian hope
here, Kibbe to take us out.
Come on, man.
- Markets work and I'm
old enough to remember
and we've had this argument over drinks.
I'm old enough to remember
when we're all scared to death
that Microsoft and Windows were gonna be
this forever dominant thing.
And it just wasn't true, it's never true.
And I think even with the
collusion between big corporations
and big governments, there's
always an innovation.
There's always a disruption.
I have a lot of faith in entrepreneurship.
And I think that despite
what the government does,
the human spirit always rises above that.
I think it's gonna be beautiful.
I've always believed that
the future is beautiful.
And I think that markets have
always cleaned up the mess
after governments have destroyed lives
and disrupted businesses
and broken people's wills.
Everything that we're
seeing happening today,
people have risen up too much
bigger challenges than that.
I'm thinking about you know what Mao did
to the Chinese people and what Hugo Chavez
and Nicolas Maduro did
to the Venezuelan people.
People can not be stopped.
Freedom cannot be stopped.
There's your optimism.
- Yeah, you did it, Kibbe.
All right, well everyone
can watch Kibbe on Liberty,
on Blaze TV.
And I look forward to seeing you in person
probably around 2024 or so.
- Well, we'll get
permission from somebody.
- (laughs loudly) Thank you, my friend.
- Thank you, sir.
- If you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlists
all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell